to welcome
to the show it's just the show you know
what show it is it's the history podcast
we do it like nobody else
right well there's people that do it
really good
probably better than us to be totally
frank but impossible but we're working
on it i mean we're trying to get better
nothing better exists i'm like i like to
sometimes be the worst hype man
welcome everybody why are you here
there's way better uses of your time and
more interesting shows to watch
but good luck ethan thank you keemstar
but
if you're choosing to stay with us we're
sponsored by mint mobile
thank you mint mobile um
yo i got a new sound bite
i saw this on like tiktok and i just
want to introduce it to the lexicon
going forward because i know it's going
to be really useful
all right um this is this has got to be
from like
csi what are they called law order yeah
law order yeah so ice cube with the
hotlines
i am not gay i have relationships with
women
and sex with men and i got news for you
that means you're gay
thoughts i mean this is great
this show is great i'm not good
i have relationships with women who have
sex with men
how old is this um not that old i don't
think it's that and i got news for you
that means you're gay yeah sorry i got
no
yeah so i was like oh dude this is gonna
be
this is going to be good
you know
for example like um so who is gay
oh my god there's so many gay sounds i
mean peace and love we are all about
acceptance but they're just funny sound
bites right
yeah you wanna hear so there's been lots
of memes coming up from the subreddit
that i think are worth reviewing this is
from the h3h3 production subreddit this
someone did a deep fake oh wow this got
twenty thousand points
so crazy magic
shout out to magic of barya and this is
one of the best defects i've ever seen
just a heads up yeah we should only show
um chunks of this because the
this guy said that the full version of
this got blocked on youtube
what but it's my face yeah but it's the
office
it got detected as a scene from the
office so what if i do it like minimize
you know what i mean
that goofs up and i think if you pause
it like halfway through and we talk for
a while and then show another chunk of
it
but if you just show it all in a row
we'll we'll get back i think if i do it
minimize it'll be fine
is it too small though can you see it if
i do this
oh hello i'm gonna do a full screen be
damned
hi what do you do i do the numbers
oh good for you this is
so bizarre this is a lot like how it's
so real
this is a lot like how we met like i
feel like i'm looking at myself and like
it looks completely accurate i am kevin
that's crazy oh no that is so sweet
thank you though yeah i keep them here
at my desk
so that everybody doesn't take them well
that is a very safe place for them
so yeah this is the episode where she
thinks kevin is uh
it's kind of like the episode where we
talk about uh you asking me to put the
snacks in a snack drawer
don't stop you know you really think
it's like that i hope it's not
so maybe it's true anyway she thinks
kevin is mentally uh
handicapped i don't know what's the word
right what's the word no
challenge no challenge well no see that
seems rude what are you challenged
what intellectually handicapped
intellectually handicapped
ela
disa disabled is what logan paul is
he's colorblind okay
yeah there she is and i got news for you
that means you're gay
oh man are we gonna really use that
soundbite because i feel like
out of context people will think we're
like well in the perfect context the
worst people
slam right you know what i mean yeah but
zach has got to chill but it's not uh
but it's not us it's the
it's them it's our show
like if they like i'm just saying in the
perfect context
it will hit so hard i agree with you as
like a slam dunk
punch line to something yeah but this
cannot be used well what about the other
guys
regularly i have we'll play the other
guy zach
what about this one
done sex with me no no the whole thing
i am not gay that's good i have
relationships with women
and sex with men and sex with men
i'm with cube on this one well i got
news for you
it's iced tea i get confused
could they have like could they have
communicated a little bit it's like
one's cube
one's iced tea there's too much ice it's
um i worry that this will take out of
context
stuff you know what that means hit it
zach
and i got news for you that means you're
gay sorry
you can't do that let's watch this so
that means you could get anything
up in the top row
that's like us on friday when i'm like
okay let's order pizza
i am totally gonna bang she's cute
and she's crazy this is exactly how we
met
this is our love story drive your own
car
okay yeah this is my car do you drive
your own car
yeah just like you
okay bye this is crazy i love it really
proud of you i love it and i hate it
because
it looks so real i'm with you i wish i
could be michael scott why do i have to
be kevin oh that would be great
we can go eat pie i love pie
okay have a good night
yeah it was a good day i mean first days
are always the hardest right
i should go i gotta buckle them in
all right you better not block our [ __ ]
that's my face
i own my face the office
yeah shout out to the magic of oh barca
i want this guy doing more damn
see the top commas ethan fits kevin so
perfectly see i don't like this
right i don't like being mentally uh
handicapped he said in the comments
uh he spent three weeks on that wow i
mean it looks
amazing yeah i'm glad that it's getting
the love it deserves because
it would be a shame for this thing to
get buried full disclosure i was
watching the office and i could not stop
seeing your face on kevin
oh after seeing this okay you know
i mean i'd love to play a kevin but i
just it hits too close to home you know
what i mean it's
very close to home
i love pie i don't know
yes that's me um here's a here's another
meme from the subreddit the summer has
been on fire lately
shout out to them shout out to the
family
awkward moment when theodore and future
siblings watch the podcast
we're taking a valentine i don't plan on
this happening by the way i'm not
they're not gonna be sitting around
watching reruns of our podcast trust me
when i put on art because we always open
youtube to play theodore
he loves stuff on youtube and when
there's
there's a thumbnail of me and eli and he
goes mommy daddy
because he sees this on the tv and i
click it and he goes no no
no he hates it he hates watching us
he thinks it's so boring i hate it too
we
can we're staying home but without did
or which is code for
i don't know she's ovulating oh
we're gonna so
i really gotta put everything out there
don't you
breaking news theodore sorry to break it
to you yes we've had sex
[Music]
welcome to the office
yeah do you feel
like is this office harassment
i guess i could harass my wife
technically no it's not harassment it's
embarrassment okay um some people might
consider that the same thing
if you sue me though you're basically
suing yourself right
what do i get out of it don't sue me bro
we have a joker brain mean from
subreddits
again i'm not lying there's all kinds
him i'm joker brain baby her what's the
craziest thing you've done
chucky mayonnaise really joker brains
out there zach
proving them all wrong you gotta do it
man gotta live that life
we love it i feel like because he told
everyone that i'm ovulating
i kind of want to share that i actually
didn't ovulate
what happened i don't know so
nothing so so then i'll let him know
when the next time
yeah well we'll keep everybody updated
on your ovulating schedule
you know it's important
they say that they say that females get
synced up
i wonder if our female audience gets
synced up to you
um weird to think about isn't it
sync me or ovulation yeah it's weird
i hate the whole thing i just want to be
pregnant already
yeah well just remember how miserable
being pregnant is though
i know which is part of like why it's so
annoying because
we're not even through the hard part
just want to get it done
yeah yeah talk to me baby
does vin diesel have kids i wonder
anyway who knows it's a good question
oh thank you or not
i thought it does i don't know talk to
me baby i wonder how he talks to his
kids
hey talk to me
look how beautiful she is huh he does
tell me about his family a.b um
he has three kids i believe and he's
documented
after uh paul walker his daughter's
pauline oh
they're after paul walker that's sweet
yeah
talk to me baby i want to feed that's
what he says to his wife
he says to his wife at least three times
talk to me baby
oh little uzi ver
so by the way i didn't talk someone
saved me
so today we're talking about v tubers
the phenomenon
and we're actually having a call in from
code mikko
who's super interesting a fascinating
character
amazing character on twitch who's a v2
purpose you got the whole body
the legs the hands we found out
that there were nipples on her at one
point but then there's not nipples on
her character
so stay tuned we learned out a lot of
interesting stuff she's awesome i'm a
fan
papa why
but before we get to that that you know
okay i'm really fascinated by this whole
thing about
lil uzi vert implanting a 24 million
dollar
pink diamond on his face i have a lot of
questions about this here let me pull
this up
so
here broke
okay here's a here's a photo so
apparently i don't
it's so okay first of all little uzi is
not
that big of a deal i don't think he's
worth 24 million dollars
so my question is how does he afford it
that's my my question too either the
i think he's greatly exaggerating the
price or
he's got some craziest loan out for this
diamond
or he's bigger than we think he's not
bigger ian is he bigger than we think
i mean he's mid-level medium-sized wait
abs nodding yes you think he's a big
deal
i think he is yeah you think he's got 24
million to spend on this [ __ ]
i mean i don't know if he's that rich
but
he does get a lot of streams his numbers
are always high he's always like top 15.
is that right didn't you say he had like
two
i mean spotify says i think 25 million
monthly listeners that's nothing that's
very low that we get that many views on
our youtube channel
i mean a lot of these artists little uzi
vert type
artists get a lot from festivals concert
tours things like that
yeah you ain't making it right now so
yeah you don't have no pink diamond
money
okay let me type i don't know and it's
crazy
for net worth but like i mean
first of all oh see this is 16 million
so
that's pretty good but that ain't no
[ __ ] pink diamond
anyway he's put it in his forehead like
the dude from avengers
and i don't know if this is like a chalk
remove because lil uzi vert was the
weird cult guy right
ian yeah did a whole presentation on
yeah dude does a diamond really cost
24 million dollars just for the stone is
that a real thing
here's him from uh instagram story i'm
gonna be right there
someone's actually in the middle
is john in the middle i just
got a long bar in it because i just got
it pierced and
the swelling when the swelling go down
short bar
so it won't move oh jesus
i know that's a flex on even somebody's
office
don't touch that it doesn't look secure
bro dude someone was just gonna nick
that right off his [ __ ] forehead
yeah it's kind of scary to be walking
around like that nice background ian
abby you're saying jewelers give rappers
a deal to advertise business i mean
that's a 20 million dollar
yeah well it's probably exaggerated but
also yeah they give them deals sometimes
like
johnny dang back in the day he used to
do that with like a lot of the grills
that we've seen a lot of music videos
like in 2004
like i get that but this but not with
something like this no yeah
i mean it's spot in the middle of his
head might be how is that
advert for them though because the it
like if you look it up it'll tell you
where he got the diamond
you'll see the the name of the uh that's
a horrible investment
photo those over mil
i can't get over this he implanted it in
his [ __ ] head you guys
like what the hell am i supposed to make
of this world we live in
i mean the piercing
your forehead i've seen done before so
but
it's more it's just the price tag that's
really shocking
like it's gotta be like fairly heavy so
i'm assuming that
his skin is gonna because it's it's a
piercing through his
yeah if it's heavy it could droop like
he's gonna droop earrings
and you know someone's just going to be
like see ya i'd be like thanks 20
million
i'm doubting the price of that though to
me that's like a few million dollar
diamond
but what the [ __ ] do i know i'm not i'm
not spending no 20 million
let me see 20 million dollar diamond
find me a picture of a 20 million
diamond here let's see
i mean i don't know why are diamonds so
expensive
it's just [ __ ] there's like a whole
backstory about how
debris to do beers like limits the
amount of diamonds that goes out in the
market
to increase the rarity i think diamonds
were at one point super rare
because they're they're just the way
that they're formed in the earth and
a lot of the value comes from the
clarity the perfection of the diamond
if it's cloudy or something
but now um they've like journeyed to the
center of the earth and have just like
mountains of diamonds
as i understand it and and to be
unlocked
diamonds yeah and to be totally frank
with you i don't know anything
got it so there's that to consider
got it so there you have it this is the
most expensive uh
pink diamond ever sold according this
article i just googled was
32 million so like
this basically means that he bought the
most expensive pink diamond which
well no this was not the most but like
up there for sure
yeah up there i just wasn't sure if it
was even like realistic but it sounds
like it kinda is
i guess i mean it is a fat [ __ ]
diamond is this do you think there's
a power chakra play i wonder if he's
gonna be paying for it for the rest of
his life like
what how do you pay that much
yeah i think you must have got a loan
for that so much
but that shot you can't you can't put a
price on that chakra that's mad chakra
ian do you what do you make of this
because you're familiar with little izu
is this a chakra play is this a flex
what's going on here
well maybe he's on blocking chakra maybe
there's some
some chakra chakras going on here
he's very i don't look i saw uncut gems
one time
i don't know i don't know well you know
about him though i'm just wondering if
you know anything about him
yeah i mean little little lucifer was
fur i don't know he's doing
i don't know what these [ __ ] people
do a little cutie squirt
yeah people are people are joking that
basically
he's got the infant one of the infinity
gems that's why i say that's mad chakra
if you can
if you can get an infinity gem for 20
million i mean that's actually a good
price
thanos would have paid that for sure
abe what do you know about this guy you
said pink looks nice it's a nice diamond
i like the pink
you want that i'll get you that i'll get
you whatever you want i'll [ __ ]
i will i'll have zach go nick it off his
forehead i would never
want to spend that much money on
that zach will knick it it's like i
couldn't care less
done i really couldn't care what if it
was like 10 000.
that's a big difference that's a huge
difference yeah 10
000. i can live with that yeah okay
i'll see what i can get you zach we'll
talk after the show
you got it you know someone scheming a
nick that off his forehead
already definitely i mean
they're just gonna yank it off like a
[ __ ] pimple it's just
that's horrible just thinking about that
yeah well
that's the price of having crazy chakra
anyway interesting
oh the here for so here he's saying
they're saying that um
he has he's been one of the highest paid
rappers in the world
for real for instance he earned 20
million from september 2017 to september
what 2018 a huge chunk of which came
from his touring
according to pole star lil uzi vert
demands as much as sixty thousand
dollars for every concert so let's see
apparently he makes sixty thousand
dollars per show the diamond costs
twenty million
how many shows so how he's gonna have to
do
three hundred that's not that much 330
shows yeah it's doable that's in a year
that's a year's work
yeah all right 530 shows in a year
that's just 330 non-stop touring i mean
that's
well yeah but but sometimes these guys
play like two or three shows in the same
venue mm-hmm
true but yeah i mean that's definitely
that's that adds up yeah he could pay
that off in a few years
but that's that's just a parent's fee
though that's not his own
that's where he he appears right that's
not
actual you think that's just for him
showing up and being like yo what up
it's me
for every concert that he graces
really they pay his attention that makes
a lot more on tour he's known he's
always on tour
[ __ ] i guess he also got diamond money
people get a cut
of whatever he makes too like managers
and
yeah sure yeah shaved off like a diamond
i have friends in in uh in in like
mainstream media with the managers and
the agents and the touring and the venue
it's great do they end up making like
you know
50 of what they're actually getting paid
at the end of the day
it's like holy [ __ ]
again a b is writing for little uzi
raid uh his uh charted number one
really his album charted number one
i guess he does have diamond money
you kidding huh well good for him i
don't know that
i would uh support that decision i'm
getting a [ __ ] diamond on my forehead
bro i gotta flex
a little uzi didn't he tweet at me ian
or was that somebody else that wasn't
him that was true
oh well tracy tweeted he was talking mad
[ __ ] to me on twitter
yeah little tracy is not a big deal is
he
not like closing that'd be awesome if
lil uzi was [ __ ] talk to me on twitter
so if hypothetically i got a 32 million
dollar pink diamond attack
and put it on my forehead do you think
he would notice me
for sure best friends
i think he'd be jealous yeah probably
all right let's move on who cares
anyway shout out to his family
oh more from a b little uzi vert
got [ __ ] in the past for saying his fans
are going to hell with him
yeah he started a concert and he's like
if you're here he said something along
the lines if you're here you're going to
hell
like don't deny it or something like
that it doesn't seem like that big of a
deal
i thought he was ascending to the
heavens with the aliens
i got it i didn't think there was a
whole like spiritual aspect to this too
let's talk about what can only i talked
about this story on frenemies
it was mentioned to me in passing by
trisha because it just happened but i
want to show it to you ela because it's
truly and it's about charlie dimiglio
and i have to say this with peace and
love she's 16 years old
and i as much as i hate talking about or
let's just say quote-unquote making fun
of a 16
year old and would never and would
loathe to do that
this story is like so compelling
that i have to talk about it and you
guys will understand why when i say it
because i've truly never seen anything
like this in my whole
career on the internet
and um it's probably the most
embarrassing thing i've ever seen happen
to another human being
so with peace and love i have to tell
this story
so here's the story there is and correct
me if i'm wrong ian because you know the
you know charlie
xcx is a musician
who's so far so good okay great thank
you
and whose friend and and producer
uh wait okay her friend and producer
sophie passed away in a tragic accident
where she just like tripped or something
when she was skiing
tragic she was just
part wow something they never said the
details but
just that she felt today
she fell i mean she fell i mean that's a
hell of a way to
die they they made it sound like she
just like tripped and fell
something oh awful roofia that sucks
just tragic
okay and so people were like wow
you know they started trending the
hashtag here for charlie
for this musician charlie xcx
now charlie demilio saw this trending on
twitter
and mistakenly meant thought it was for
her
stand with tr i stand with charlie
interestingly that means that
she probably didn't read through the
hashtag or
i don't know but so she saw this
trending
here for charlie and she tweeted this
out
i am looking through the here for
charlie hashtag
and oh my goodness you are all so sweet
to me you have no idea how much your
kind words
warm my heart i am so lucky to have you
all by my side i love you babes
so like she's accepting the condolences
for someone else whose friend died
that's a hell of a blunder like i wonder
what the tweets were
that she saw i mean how could you
mistake it for
her like sorry for your loss
i i can only imagine maybe this article
has some examples of the tweets
here for charlie what what did she think
they were supporting her for
you know what i mean just our struggles
just yeah i mean
the one day that um she was sad
you know but i i i
i
i was really really really really sad
anyway listen with peace and love
incredible stuff here you know uh trisha
said it
i mean she's a six-year-old girl trisha
said maybe they got it together off
tick-tock and put her back in school i
don't know
don't do the stooges i mean she's come
on zach be respectful
she's 16 for christ's sake
but i do feel like that maybe is a
wake-up call when you start accepting
the condolences of
past weird here for charlie
you're all so sweet trying to think what
you what what was she reading
like i'm so sorry for your loss she's
like oh thank you yes i've lost so much
yeah i've lost so much to being famous
so sorry for what you're going through
yeah
hang in there we love you you'll get
through this she's like thank you
i know it's tough my life is hard i'm
just hard
you're very special so crazy though
that she was just 34. yeah it's really
tragic inside thoughtful
she fell off her roof that's crazy well
it said she was
climbing up to look at the moon and then
oh my god oh no
wow that's scary i don't like that
horrible
yeah no there's this you know and and
hashtag here for charlie all the way
just you know not this one
i am here for her
i just pulled up on twitter and just
searched hashtag here for charlie
and i mean there's no way that she could
have looked at it yeah read a song i
mean
uh hashtag here for charlie hoping you
feel better soon charlie xcx you deserve
so much love and happiness well maybe
she thought xxx yeah
like xoxo right you deserve so much love
and happiness thank you guys
i am just i love it thank you she's
getting love bomb go ahead read me more
ah
here for charlie i love you love you my
favorite
my favorite pick of charlie and sophie
there's pictures
she's like oh that that that's clearly
not you
yeah i don't know she must have just not
actually looked at it
she just saw charlie trending and
assumed it was for her
yeah i never heard of anything like this
and then people were just shocked and
odd and then when they saw the her tweet
obviously people were just blown the
[ __ ] away
and like here let me read some of the
comments people left people were saying
like um
well you can imagine apparently her
tweet was up for a while too even as
people were correcting her
um
charlie charlie xcx the passing of her
close friend sophie please respect that
no way charlie demilio thought here for
charlie was for her
laugh my ass off does no one realize
this tag isn't meant for charlie dimigio
i'm screaming charlie demilio thanks
here for charlie is for her
laugh crying emoji
uh actually you know i got to feel bad
for this girl sophie because the whole
thing turned into a [ __ ]
circus because she started accepting
everyone's condolences and everyone got
confused
hell of a hell of a move man
look we all learn lessons at some point
in life do you you need to take a moment
and think and analyze before you act
right
i only learned that lesson like a few
months ago so
you know what i mean i can't hate on i
i'm not hating on her you know it's just
unfortunate
there you have it
what'd you thank you though i don't know
your build up for the story was a little
bit over the top well when i heard it at
the
i mean the shock and awe was a little
worn off because when i first heard it
i know the jaw dropped yeah but i heard
it too i mean i watch frenemies
well maybe not everybody watches friend
me didn't know the story i mean it's
pretty amazing
like the build-up was a little bit much
no stop
we're at uh the 30-minute mark by the
way all right let's go ahead and thank
uh
mint mobile and when we come back we all
are gonna reveal
our much anticipated v
tubers we all have v2 bar avatars that
we have been in the laboratory
programming we have been doing the code
and i'm just
super excited to unveil so much time the
efforts of
thousands of hours of work so stay tuned
after this brief thank you to our
sponsor
after the year we've all been through
saving money should be at the top of
everyone's resolution list because let's
face it the government doing [ __ ] to
help you
that's not the copy that's just me it
should be like while the government
squabbles over giving tax cuts to
billionaires you're
stuck with pretty much nothing so you
should be saving money with mint
mobile let's face it internet
and wireless bills for mobile is in
still insanely
expensive switching to mint mobile is
the easiest way to save this year
they're the very first company to sell
premium wireless services
online only which lets you maximize your
savings
with plans that start at just 15 a month
now
i know phone bills these days like you
know unlimited
100 bucks a month is still running which
is absolutely insane you could get on
mint mobile 15
a month that's 75 a month that's a lot
of money to save every month
damn that's huge that's like 75 snicker
bars
actually sometimes you can get it for
less if there's a good deal maybe
maybe there's 150 snicker bars on a good
day i have no idea
it's been a long time since i've been
aroused but i'm just guessing
i'm trying to put that i'm trying to
make it relatable you know you want to
put it you want to put a snake
of ours okay what are you spending your
75 dollars on that's 75 rolls of toilet
paper
everyone can relate to that shirley
for people looking for extra savings
this year mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just fifteen dollars a
month
by going online only and eliminating
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes the significant
savings on to you all plans come with
unlimited talk
and text plus high-speed data delivered
on the nation's
largest 5g net oh my god it's 5g stop
stop daddy
wow that's a good deal use your own
phone
with any mint mobile plan and keep your
same phone number along with all your
existing contacts stop
this is way too good if you're not 100
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their seven day money back
guarantee
stop this is unbelievable offer
switch to mint mobile and get stop stop
switch to mint mobile and get the
premium wireless service starting at
just 15
a month to get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com
h3 that's mint dot com slash
h3 cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month
at mintmobile.com h3
okay we're back before the vtuber thing
there's one thing i forgot
that logan paul got absolutely
obliterated
stepping to the foot soldier army now
you may recall that
step right let's can i get some feed
emojis in the chat i thought people
started doing that that was pretty epic
pretty funny now recall he had a pretty
good score he was at a 4.6 definitely an
admirable score
now i'm not gonna flex i don't i'm not
one to tap dance on my
on on someone's grave but he's at a 1.07
now okay
which let's be honest embarrassing
humiliating
shameful i'm surprised even okay i'm
surprised he
even would walk around with sandals or
open-toed shoes anymore after this
um it's a it's a it's an annihilation
so shout out to the foot shout out to
his family
oh now i'm a strawberry
stupid-ass and bull i do want to again
just
he is disabled so i'm gonna go light on
him stop
he's colorblind he you see what ian is
saying
he himself said he's disabled i'm only
repeating what he said
um ian during the break got a jam
installed in his face
yeah the check cleared from oreos so i
thought i'd
you know you upgrade your chakra bruh
get a little bling
fix the chakras were you going to the
bathroom by chance
mercury was in retrograde
for gabe's you were going to the
bathroom during the break
right i'm always going to the bathroom
during the break
hmm interesting why are you asking well
i got a piece
so bad why do you want to know bruh well
it just so happens that uh
we may have something to exact do you
have a song
i do have a song i don't i didn't have
it cued up though okay
you're not ready oh i thought you were
ready for it no no no
okay let's just erase that then i
thought i was i was setting you up
i can play though i mean
you want to do it or you want to wait
till it's great well i mean it has a
full lyric video and
i feel like it would let's wait then
let's wait okay
yeah okay e
ins flow
what ian's monitor there was text on it
sorry it was an ad come on
people got to pay beyond this [ __ ]
step it back step it back we're talking
about ian's chakra
speaking of ads and speaking of uh ian
um
can you give some feedback to gaga we we
tried those
oreos on frenemies the other day they
[ __ ] suck man
they're awful yeah you guys caused me a
really a pr nightmare with that one you
keep looking in the middle are you
looking at your thing
because your eyes keep crossing yeah i
don't really know what are you talking
about
oh my god dude i think your chakras are
disaligned i can't start my characters
no your chakras are all out of whack bro
can you do that let me try i can't do it
and i can't look at it
am i doing it am i doing it a little bit
not
not as good as that i need something
like this here you are bullying me no
[ __ ] yeah well get a get an oreo
sponsorship and you could give birth
that's bad chakra bro
oh my god you are bullying me i'm not
anyway um people are calling logan
paul's podcast
this is good again i want to give
soldiers out there
he should change the name of his podcast
to report repulsive
shout out to r that's just their name r
yeah what is his name how is it not
repulsive
it's repulsive oh impulsive impulsive
stupid ass is that really a good name
it's like dude you filmed a dead body do
you really want to go by
impulsive like you want to go by
restrained respectable you don't want to
be
known as impulsive like that's what got
you in the [ __ ] to begin with
listen you know we have a branding issue
with impulsive
repulsive
anyway there's more keemstar of course
are arch nemesis
uh but the enemy of my enemy is my
friend in this case i guess i don't know
i don't wanna i don't want to uh make
light of how much i dislike keemstar
so i don't i i i i'm hesitant to even
show this because i don't want it to
seem like i like keemstar in any way
but i do think it's funny because i knew
because keemstar is as petty of a [ __ ]
as if
it's me as if not more i mean i joke
about being a petty [ __ ] but keemstar
is really like
a different breed you know what i mean
so i was like of course keem's going to
go on it's going to be
painting okay i'll prove it i even
responded with this i forgot i did that
i was just
i was just i just don't like him
very important stuff i need to talk to
you about very comfortable story
stop there it's not important because
the thing is he's not being ironic
he's like very important stuff no
very important stuff i need to talk to
you about we covered a story about roman
atwood
uh he's being correct i mean they put
bomb threats in his mom's funeral
they shut down his electric uh to his
house they shut down his insurance
they hacked all the stuff they had to
say apparently literally would take
pictures from his own security cameras
in his own house
and send it to his cell phone to the
point where the fbi got involved now
here's where things change logan paul
responds to this saying
roman atwood is a nice guy and he's got
kids why attack
roman atwood why don't these people go
after scums of the internet
like keemstar and h3h3
first of all i have kids
h3h3 has right and why why would you
even
say that logan that's straight fast up
trying to get people to rest
i hate h3h3 he is the scum of the earth
whoa so you're backing him up
that's what he said about me
scum of the earth that's even more than
anything yeah
he took it even further than logan by
the way
being hated by keemstar is honestly a
badge of honor like if keemstar likes
you you should check your [ __ ]
pulse but i wouldn't want any of my fans
to harass him in real life
thank you and i would hope you shut up
you know i wouldn't
get the same respect back from ethan
that he wouldn't want his fans to harass
me and really the only way my fans would
ever harass you is on wiki feet
and they have even though his fans did
and shut up shut up
what fans shut up stupid ass
even though what was that game
what was that i dare you to say the
whole thing keemstar go ahead i dare you
death to all jews that's what i thought
that's what i thought
mask off that really did happen even
though
that my sponsor at the time h3's fans
threatened them
in real life even though that really
happened you know
neither one of us i would assume and i
hope
wouldn't want no the golden boy
uh of youtube recently he's not the
golden boy but kind of like logan paul
i guess he's right he's getting too much
credit yeah he's right that um
uh keemstar is to make fun of you for
being the golden boy
of youtube remember that god it's been a
long time since i've been the golden boy
i was a golden boy
for yeah that was fun being yeah when
everyone likes you
the problem is when everybody likes you
that's when you go [ __ ] that's when
they're scrutinizing every stupid
[ __ ] thing you do to prove that
now everybody knows i'm an [ __ ] and
it's a little more like liberating
i could never do this show back then you
know what i mean
yeah no it's it's not sustainable you
don't want to be the golden boy trust me
being the golden boy sucks it's fun
while it lasts though
you know not on us
that's [ __ ] up for you to send your
podcast that is
so [ __ ] up and wrong and you owe me an
h383 a giant apology
[ __ ] you logan paul i understand that
you're mad that i said there's no hype
for your [ __ ] fight
i get it but
how you're going about it suggesting
that me and h3h3 should be harassed in
real life
that our families that our girlfriends
our wives our children should be
harassed in real life that is
so [ __ ] up and wrong go let me finish
it oh [ __ ] yourself logan paul
it's so funny yeah i mean look i agree i
mean i'm right there with uh
keemstar on that one yeah for once in
our life i mean i pretty much said the
same thing i was like listen i don't
think me
or keemstar would wish that on
each other i certainly know well
keemstar has an
uh history of um wishing it on people
but maybe it's changed i'll be for
myself i wouldn't
yeah you know
i'm gonna take your kids college fund
and it's making me happy
right he did say that they did wish a
couple of things wait he did say that
about me
still waiting on him to take the college
fund
what was he going to take the college
from for because i said
he said he's gonna sue me for slander or
something i don't remember
what is it i said he said i slandered
him for a b you know all this stuff
don't you
it's the whole video yeah it's just yeah
for
the video that made him lose sponsors
so basically i'm just doing a little
update on the wiki feed
on the keemstar and basically so we can
put logan paul in the thumbnail and say
something like
logan paul obliv obliterated
by the foot soldier army something like
that ian sound good
roger that logan paul
logan paul career is over
after the foot soldier army stomped him
out of existence
logan fall well said a.b logan fall
on the repulsive podcast
that's so good anyway [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] let's talk about v
tubers all right so we're gonna i'm
gonna have to do like a quick fade cut
here so we can set up all of our
our avatar so let's cut we'll be right
back
okay we are back i am ethan klein your
host
also known as lord borgore
and i am lady big titties
so eliz is awesome because the titties
jiggle when she moves her head
like holy [ __ ] bro yes daddy
can't you like this
that's awesome i might be a burger but
i'm still hungry
it's funny that i need to move my head
to get them to move
see try to make them jiggle as much as
possible i think
try to do like a big circle like a big
circle motion oh yeah
let those titties bounce but yeah
so let's introduce everybody's avatar i
gotta say this burger is like super
expressive yeah
either yours my girl like doesn't move
it's all about the titties you don't
even look at the face go ahead and talk
me yeah she's like a really meek
enemy girl her mouth doesn't open very
much when she talks
hey my name is hi what's a good anime
name
hi my name is akama sakura hi
my name is akama i'm new here
will you be my friend
don't please ignore my giant bouncing
titties
i didn't realize i had giant bouncing
titties
they're just so big and so real big
milkers
no not fake at all they're
all right let's see who else we got
dan you want to introduce yourself so
i'm very uh
i'm the sunder girl i'm i'm angry at you
baca ethan chan for uh disrupting the
flow of the show
the voice does not match though
you're gonna have to talk to be kind of
exaggerated
you have to talk in a female voice i
have to be kind of exaggerated
for it to properly track so dan what
does it say anything about you that you
are a female avatar maybe
um i wonder if ice t has anything to say
about it
uh this is just this is my inner uh
this is my inner being and uh how dare
you um
even question it okay okay and i got
news for you
that means you're gay huh oh oh
what do you say to that dad that's right
speaking of zach zach what the heck is
going on with you
joker brain i've gone full
joker brain huh you know
well speaking of joker brain zack your
internet sucks he lives with his parents
his internet's it's like dude come on
man we got you got to get good internet
like i do pay you enough
i mean yeah like enough
i mean yeah yeah i think we're there
what's going on here
because you're what are we gonna do
about your internet
uh it's joker brand internet so i
can't really uh bro i can't just use
joker brain is an excuse for everything
you have a responsibility
to come here with workable internet
i mean we depend on you you know look at
my eyes they close the onion's closed
that's kind of cool look at this i can't
the burger is kind of the best one it's
so expressive
ian also looking very kawaii we love
that what do you
what do you got going on over there ian
uh i'm domino's salesman hatsune miku
oh is that really her yes uh-uh
that's awesome you know it's funny
trisha thought she was the most prolific
pizza salesman
i've got news for her
yeah beat it oh my god choose two or
more is mix and match deal 5.99 out now
i was just going to ask if you have a
promo for us i connect you up
does is there anything odd about you
choosing a female avatar
iced tea
iced tea iced tea what does it mean that
he chose to not have a hello
i see i said slow ass internet
look at zach's avatar struggling to find
the sound bite
[Laughter]
i see you appreciate it look at zach
struggling over there
some killer clown who's frantically
looking back and forth
zach was doing the best joker impression
earlier i just really like
to hear it on the show just a quick
sample he does all the best stuff off
the show let's hear it
i was not doing a joker impression oh
that was a real
ian i think that's
you wait turn it off turn off his thing
let me see if ian's [ __ ] around
i'm not i'm not that's funny
why is my character like so she won't
move
because you're all so excited because
all that matters is my titties bouncing
when i move my head
my name is uh they programmed all the
expression into this yeah
it is nice to live as a big breasted
i'm eating that girl look at that
i wanna bite that look at those
knockers that's gonna be
dude the amount of male attention you
get if you have big ass or like fake
kids with a tight top
yeah insane it's like living on another
planet you should have seen the avatar i
had earlier it's
way too obscene very nice
damn can you shake that for me one more
time
okay great success
okay all right all right jesus zach
god damn ab what's going on with you who
we got
is that a what is that is that a minion
or something else what is that it's a
snail
oh yeah i just found out it's a snail
wait why are you so small
that's what she said i don't know i just
it's just
oh but you're sitting in the chair but
it looks like
there you go there you go now we go it's
kind of cute
he's adorable it's really it's really
emotes well too
yeah what is this some kind of character
for something
the software comes with a bunch of
default ones it's cool i mean he's a
cool character he's got like crystals or
some [ __ ]
no these are just cloud pills while of
all the avatars here
ela i'm happy to say is the one that i
would
ah i don't know how to put this lightly
smash
what about now whoa oh my goodness that
is obscene
look at the size i'll tell you what
you cannot you could spread cheese on at
least 20 pies with those milkers
you know what i'm saying it's like am i
looking through a fish-eye lens like
why is it so out of proportion because
it's anime bro that's how we roll
and like the nipples hanging through
there like little claws
oh that's the nipple yeah so what
honestly i'd still rather uh slam my
wife
sadly ian good i'm not a fan of those
big
mommy droopers
[Laughter]
you know it really really really upsets
me how much attention big-breasted women
get
right i'm with her okay dancing to the
role playing here
thank you dan thank you dan you know um
the eyes do work so we were talking
about so we're going to talk about v
tubers so
v tubers is this whole craze
started trending in japan in the mid
2010s
it's super popular in japan on youtube
and live streaming
and um actually on youtube one of the
largest super chat earners of all time
is a view v tuber that's crazy
of all time of last year
and they met they netted approximately
eight hundred and ten thousand dollars
from super chat
that's a million dollars of donors not
just one of them
seven of the ten largest wait what
seven of the ten whoa are they even are
they doing english speaking or is this
all happening in like japan and we don't
even know about it
uh well i think the one that you're
looking at is a japanese one
oh wow it's crazy yeah they have their
whole ecosystem going on there
interestingly a lot of the comments are
like show your feet and stuff which
we'll get into
um wow million dollars oh wait you can't
see it all right i think
yeah it's either trying to show her feet
holy [ __ ]
i was wondering if it would show your
legs like
no that you need a whole tracking suit
for that yeah well i was telling like
the one of the guys on the crew should
just ought to go out there and
get a voice changer you can be rich man
yeah i mean it would be a fun experiment
just to see how big
i could get kind of like the
spiderman and elsa venture but
this is even smarter you don't even need
to show yourself right
i don't think there's a voice changer
convincing enough though
to convince people that i'm actually
female do you dan
uh i'm like your voice is pretty deep
too
hi my name is burger boy would you like
to see my feet
oh dan said it was hot what do you think
about that ice cube
ice cube dan i need you to get it
because you asked
dan i gotta get you to get a sound bite
of the jeopardy
like done the final jeopardy so when
zach takes too long you get in with that
okay or like 16 minutes
uh tick tock i have that one i've done
that to him before
right keep the pressure on the pressure
is on
joker
so anyway super popular you know i was
fully unaware of this whole trend
same and i have heard about um
there's this one this one girl is making
huge waves
that we're actually coming she's coming
on shortly to do an interview with us
super interesting
um mikko
i know i said miku by accident no it is
mikko
my name is miko and i don't have any
friends in this town
do you need me or do you need a main
service i am currently looking for work
to clean houses
i'm very poor i need all the help i can
get
big-ass titties i never seen anyone
dressed like that what's going on in
anime like i've never seen
titties like that in my life i mean i've
seen trisha kind of
no but not but they don't yeah i guess
you're right but those titties are like
i mean with peace and love i don't mean
i don't even saw her titties but look at
those things bro like
holy [ __ ]
bro i have relationships with women
yeah exactly not overcompensating
anyway super popular um
code code mikko is like
she's on another level though she's got
the whole body suit and we're going to
talk to her a lot about it she's super
interesting
but just to give you an example of
what's going on out there here's one
gar guru who's really popular 2 million
subs
they're all little interestingly you're
not i don't know
here let me sort by popular all the
popular ones are
little anime females is there any
popular male
youtubers like really popular oh
probably
like really good looking anime and male
1
did you find any a b like
snail b well ian actually took lead on
this one but
abc's did you find him or i mean sorry
ian did you see any popular male v1
big male youtuber named kazuha he's the
seventh most donated
uh there's a couple others but for the
most part seems like they're all female
so the other crazy thing is that like
there's this one huge
agency that basically owns all these
people out of japan
uh called the what are these guys called
hololive hollow live
and um yeah these people are crushing it
three million subscribers on this one
let's see
[Music]
so she must have like a whole body suit
on with gloves and arms and stuff
[Music]
yeah so we've we actually we
found some interesting donation comments
maybe you guys are interested in the
kind of people that are donating i'm not
saying this represents everybody but i
thought it was really interesting
this one says make sushi with your feet
please 200
whoa two hundred dollars for that so you
know that's not a joke right because he
said make sushi with your feet
thanks for the stream can we see your
feet
um i can't take it anymore kiara i need
you and i'm gonna travel to japan to
look for you i need to smell your c
word we had to blur it see you were
like like the one that if we can't say
in a whole podcast or youtube
demonetizes us
why would you say that word like that's
this one was really off the rails i'm
gonna read it i have grown really
attached to you
which means i think about your
well-being every day and take every
burden you have on
myself and the hope that you will feel
better i
wish i could do more but i can't and
that breaks me every day
promise one day you will do something
more i promise one day i will do
something more than donate please
don't let's leave it at donut like what
good that's the question we don't want
an answer
um what do you what do you suppose that
guy looks like that left that
comment like your burger avatar come on
give me that i swear i'm gonna do one
something more one day then
my girl doesn't even smile she's like do
a big smile
that's pretty good i have relationships
with women
yeah so um
you know and then the other thing about
the vtuber i don't know if we're gonna
get [ __ ] for doing this
maybe i'm hoping that we won't get [ __ ]
from the v tube community because i'm
looking like a burger and we're not
actually trying to be v
tubers right i think that's what their
friends probably
there's people that got into the
youtuber fray like pokeman and pewdiepie
they actually got a lot of [ __ ] from
people which is interesting people are
very
possessive about this um
the v tuber craze i mean doesn't it just
kind of mean you're going mainstream
which is good
well i guess certainly that's one
argument i guess it's good and bad
because it just means
whenever something goes more mainstream
it also gets shittier
there's just more people but it seems
like
i don't know i don't like people who
gatekeep it's like you're the annoying
one just let everyone have fun i mean i
i think
it's just really interesting and i can
see why you know someone like
someone who does daily videos and
looking for content i could see why they
would want to
try this out right it's just fun you
think people watch me as a burger
do you think people donate i like the
melted cheese when you open your mouth i
know i can't
satisfying to see that
so anyway um
ian your eyes are all over the place bro
what the f
that's i can't control them look at
those eyes bro
i'm not buying any dominoes from this
go on get the breadsticks i'm not
getting any breadsticks from you
freak what's happening to her
dipping sauce is pretty good no no
look i got plenty of different sauce
look at this
anyway here's pokemane so pokeyman tried
the v tuber thing
you know seems innocent and fun she's
just having fun
so if you guys didn't know there's
already a she made a custom one
they're called there's a huge it's a
seven hour [ __ ] stream jesus christ
people work hard it kind of works
there's a huge
huge
anyway that's you know for seven hours
whatever but this guy just to give you
an idea
this dude made a whole vid see how angry
this guy got about it it's pretty
fascinating
this dude um and leave it this dude
rev says desu and he's got an anime
my profile picture yeah anime profile oh
it's going to be a good take
so he says please stop this it has 360
000 views and overwhelming like
majority so his views are well
represented i guess by
by his audience and give it to the
internet's biggest karen pokeman
to come in and ruin it for everyone i
mean look at this design
i don't know what she paid for she is
ruining exactly
like what if she's ruining it for you
that's your problem
it just it's bizarre logic i mean it's
just
interesting it's a little too fragile of
her doing it one
like that is ruining it for everyone
like bro chill holy [ __ ]
but she needs a refund honestly it's not
even a v tuber
it's just a model of herself like what's
the point don't unleash this plague upon
this community
i know youtubers are bigger than ever
right now but i hope to god it doesn't
reach that critical breaking point where
everyone in their autistic cousin
becomes a v tuber to milk
the autistic thing no
harsh yeah look out this niche until
it's bone dry and overused
how was this even made are we uh sure i
hope that
me i hope that me sitting here as a
burger
talking about is ushering in the end of
the whole
era i hope that i am ruining v tubers
forever for you
and i would love to see you make a video
criticizing a talking burger assuring
in the end i hope that
me talking as a burger will up is the
ushering
end of the era for you and that you make
a video showing me talking as a burger
look at those titties though you know
that's why we're here girl
face me ah putting those cities in my
house give me some swingers
it doesn't move it doesn't have them
abilities
yeah this is definitely the end of
youtubers as we know
i actually enjoy watching this guy get
so angry though let's continue
it's fun knit for everyone i mean look
at this design
i don't know what she paid for this but
she needs a refund honestly it's not
even a v
tuber it's just a model of herself like
what's the point chill don't unleash
this plague upon this community
i know v tubers are bigger than ever
right now but i hope to god it doesn't
reach that critical breaking point where
everyone in their autistic cousin
becomes a v tuber to milk out this niche
until it's bone dry and overused
how is this even made in ms paint this
looks like an elementary school arts and
crafts project that wouldn't even earn
us angry
i think the funniest part is the fact
she thought it was shouldn't that
threaten them even less like it's not
even on their level right
it's just she's just kind of trying and
by the way she's giving homage to your
this community you care about i mean
having more people there should um
should be good for your community but i
don't know he needs something to be
angry about
i can't i mean it looks i'm always
trying to looking for things to get
angry about
seems that he's overreacting though you
could tell he's reading a script
as much necessary in the first place
like people wanted this
the reason real v tubers are successful
is because they have really
coupled with entertaining personalities
like what is she gonna do as a v tuber
anyways
eat a bowl of cereal while she watches
youtube videos in her new avatar
and i know some of you that's a leafy
joke by the way saying all she does is
um she streamed for seven hours
like oh my god reb take it easy you
don't want to harass the supreme karen
and face her wrath
just to clarify i'm not making fun of
pokeman the person
i'm just taking a piss of this god-awful
v tuber abomination of a persona
they are two different people and that's
what she's going for right
i don't know final point here when she
was out here trying to take away
sponsorships from creators because they
made valid critiques of her whatever
i saw a lot of people in the comments so
in this video saying like um
there was no need to trash the
artist who made her right her costume
i don't see one anyway i just i was just
fascinated by how angry he was the fact
that he just made a youtuber
i don't know so here i am fodder for the
war
baby i hope somebody jizz in my mouth
cheese
i'm ready for it daddy shoot her right
here and i got news for you
that means you're gay oh [ __ ]
well [ __ ] it
um
daddy daddy
i'm just seeing what i can do anyway uh
pewdiepie just made a v tuber for gags
and got [ __ ] on majorly from the v tuber
community
now i don't know if this was
representative of the whole community
because again i'm not
super in tune but there are some people
clearly who are
very upset about this pewdiepie had a
pretty good response
here you say pretty funny i thought
response i also saw i got cancelled
recently because uh
v tubers were mad about me using a face
uh i don't know what to call it like an
anime filter
which is amazing my
special favorite comment was the ones
complaining that
it was an ugly anime
i might make a video like it's so funny
but
i like this thing people go through the
extra mile of hiding their appearance
online
so they can cr criticize other people's
fake appearances
online they're like wow yeah it is
pretty ironic
i i have to agree you know funnily
enough his
one looks so funny but in all the preset
avatars there's one that looks just like
him someone made it pewdiepie avatar he
could have used no it was like an
official release for the software
oh really yeah no it's like a pewdiepie
dlc for this program you think he got a
cut of that
i assume so i mean it was brand new
pewdiepie and everybody oh someone is
beautiful look at a b
so you think you think pewdiepie got a
cut of that
i mean he's i think he's getting ripped
off if he didn't because then
logo and everything but here's the thing
this was released in 2015.
oh my goodness i'm so late for this game
right
but the point being is like people like
getting mad at him about it
it sounds like he was ahead of the curve
he's a pioneer
dude let's see how you emote ab let's
see i don't know why
it's literally not working it just froze
on me it was working
i see him moving anyway
pretty interesting stuff um
how is everybody feeling so we i guess
we have code
is there anything else we want to
discuss before we throw it to code mikko
she's going to have all the good deets
so um i say we just throw it to her wait
let me put on my producer cam here
let's throw it to code miku
you have any last do you have any dan
has been fantastic you have any last
pitches for us uh ab
or i mean ian for pizza
for pizza well i think the meat lover's
special is pretty good okay all right
i'm not buying any dominoes from you
freak look at our eyes
did get pewdiepie to work though
pewdiepie what do you got to say give us
a brofist
how's the camera brush oh i can't show
my hands so
yeah give us a pewdiepie
remember he used to do that you know
what's crazy i've been watching
pewdiepie's channel just checking in on
him
dude how is it that minecraft became
like what all the youtubers are doing
now like holy [ __ ]
how is that game so prolific
that pewdiepie is still playing
minecraft that blows my mind
it blows my boobs away let me see those
titties one more time
oh my god oh whoa
whoa whoa hey guys
blast some cheese in my mouth
[Music]
all right let's first throw it to um
producer girl said this is horrific
that uh uh uh domino's girl's horrified
and i don't know what zack's doing
i got my nose girl zach
zach you're just kind of shitty like it
looks the coolest but
i'm not on a mac i'm on a pc because
it's not
compatible with what your thing looks
like
yeah what does that mean oh you blame it
you're blaming it on the pc
i'm joker brand what do you want oh my
god exactly
we have we need more answers from you
than that
no i'm not saying i'm not saying it's
your fault i'm just saying that
avatar there's not much emotion emoting
scaring
oh no wow jesus
that's freaky all right well let's throw
it to
code mikko who's obviously way more
interesting than we are that's right and
more knowledgeable
and has way more to say about this so i
look forward to
uh talking her so let's get her on the
phone okay
with us today is code miko
a very popular v tuber on twitch
who's back this friday right uh
yeah yeah back on
friday this friday at 4pm that's
exciting
yeah i'm really excited so
how did you get into um v tubing
um how did i get into v tubing
well i first started it my channel
in like march like end of march and
april
and um i've been doing it of 20
of last year and i've been doing it
since then
um a little bit of my background is that
i actually
worked in like live animation before and
i was doing like research and developing
for
um for live animation to for like trade
for
to make like traditional animation
studios um be more
productive um and that's kind of where i
got my skill set
so are you affiliated with any of these
big v tuber networks are you
totally independent i'm pretty solo
that's great
that's pretty impressive because by the
way something that's unique about you
too is that you
show your face oh yeah right i mean
that's pretty unusual for v tubers to
have they're to show their real
the real persona yeah for sure um
yeah i chose to show my face because
um i thought when they [ __ ] it
i mean like are we allowed to curse in
here you could say whatever that okay
okay okay um i was like
you know i i kind of wanted to show how
i did my things
because i thought it was cool to share
yeah and
i was worried about like oh what if they
like ruins immersion and stuff but
honestly i think it helps people to know
that there is a real person
that's behind the character and not a
you know because i would get these
comments that i'm a 40 year old
man and there's nothing wrong with that
you know
there's nothing wrong with being a 40
year old man doing
b tubing right but i would get a lot of
those comments and i guess
i i wanted to show like no i'm i'm like
i'm just a girl
you know doing dev stuff that's
interesting you know i was wondering
because i saw
we have our little v tubes that we're
doing here and ian one of our cast
members
is looking like he's like
he's like a really kawaii cute little
anime girl and like the titties balance
when he moves his head and stuff
and i'm like if we get you a voice
changer a convincing voice changer on
twitch you could probably have a career
do you think there's people that do that
oh yeah
oh wow yeah 100
there's there's definitely guys that
um well there's guys who identify with
their female youtuber
avatar right so right there's guys who
do that and there are there is
like there are guys who specifically you
know
do uh choose to be a female
for the reason of just economy
yeah they they um they think it will
bring them
uh viewers and yeah that's great wow
what a gig
you know i was so i was wondering if
there's really that convincing voice
changers where people wouldn't suspect
but i i don't think
so yeah although if there are we don't
know
yeah that's true we wouldn't know
yeah i mean for the longest time people
thought i was a 40 year old man
that's so funny
well i think it's really cool that you
showed that no
well yeah i mean actually just a girl
doing her thing well your tech setup is
super impressive i don't know if you
i have a i can show a video of you
because like you have the
a lot of people just have the face emote
emoting but you have a full suit with
tracking the hands and the legs and
everything
is that something you buy as is or did
you
make that oh okay so this so
i didn't make the suit from scratch
that'd be so cool i'd be like iron man
but no
so i got the suit the suit is um from
accents
and um it's the best inertia based
suit in the market um that basically
means that you don't need like a hundred
thousand dollars
worth of setup with all your cameras and
all that stuff
all you need is a suit and um
yeah let's do and then i've got uh new
gloves now
new finger tracking gloves um
yeah yeah i love that stuff it's crazy
but this one's charging right now so you
charge all the little pieces of the suit
or just the gloves
um i have to charge my accents as well
but this is the gloves they only come in
one size
oh it's like super big on you yeah it's
super big on me
but it's it's so it's fitted for my
accent so
so yeah and um uh the main
engine i use to build all my stuff is
unreal
and i don't know have you guys heard of
unreal engine yes
so um basically i developed all of my
live animation stuff it's called like
virtual production and i develop
everything inside my world and um
i integrate it with like twitch live uh
chat
so that they can like influence mikko's
world and stuff like that
that's so cool thank you
so when you do you play video games like
how do you play video games with those
gloves on
oh i don't play much video games anymore
because
i haven't played video games since like
for a long time because uh
i i do love playing video games but i
still have the time to
this this whole setup takes like all of
my time because
um not only do you have to plan for your
content but also
you yourself is making the content um
so you have to constantly kind of
fix things or engineer more things so
that people don't get bored
um yeah so it's i don't have much
time to play video games but i would
like niko to like play some games
although she's
i'm terrible at video games um
there's some we have a meme going on
that she's really good but she's
actually terrible terrible at video
games so
how do you differentiate your guys's
personality like when you be
when you become mikko oh
my god i feel like because i'm an avatar
i can just show like the really crazy
side
of myself and i have a lot of fun with
that
um like i'm pretty old so
like me as myself is kind of really
subdued but like
i meet with mikko i can just be as crazy
as i want
um what do you mean by all yeah what do
you mean by old
oh i i'm i'm 30.
i'm old as [ __ ] we're older than you
i'm 35 dude oh you guys look really good
oh stop everybody tells me
[Laughter]
the internet's so [ __ ] up that you
think that you get all the weird things
lately i started to feel like that like
oh my god i'm seeing some wrinkles and
i'm like
jeez yeah you'll see that wrinkle
so all the streamers i talked to an
interview
i'm always surprised because they've
been on the platform for like 10 years
right or like
you know six seven and i always ask them
like
how old they are and the oldest is 25
and the 25 year olds are always like oh
my god i'm so
old like i should be like the minecraft
kids all like
under 20. yeah i mean i yeah
i relate i've been like that my whole
career because we started kind of late i
didn't even start making youtube videos
until i was like 27.
so i'm old as [ __ ]
so what do you make of uh people are
very protective of the v
tube community people like pokey and
pewdiepie
got a i don't know a lot of back i don't
know what a lot is but people
they got some backlash why are people so
protective of this v
tuber this idea of what a v tuber is and
who can be a youtuber
i don't know really i don't know i can't
relate
to you oh really because um
i don't know ever because every human
being is born as a human being
so like i don't understand how
you could be protective of it i don't
know
that that mentality never really um i
never understood
i think maybe it's because i come from a
tech
side um and maybe they come more from
like a cultural
anime side but you are you accepted in
the v
tuber community it seems like you're
pretty you're
um i know i do have a few youtuber
friends
um i think i'm kind of just
uh i can't i think i'm i don't really
think about whether i'm
accepted or i just never thought about i
think that i think i am
um yeah i just
i just i don't i just do whatever um
[Music]
because i don't i i think i made a post
of like a year ago
well not a year ago like six months ago
saying like
i don't fully identify as a youtuber um
because of like
because i feel like youtubers have like
a certain type of culture and certain
type of look
and i felt like i didn't really fit into
that um
but someone made a point that v tubing
is just being virtual and just
you know youtubing or or just tubing
as a virtual character um so i was like
oh i'm like chase and i guess i do
identify as a youtuber um
but yeah i think they have a very like
anime
central culture that
i i joke and say that i'm i watch a lot
of anime i actually
don't
the only anime i've like watched this
death note
i read the manga but that that make that
gives me
credit
i feel like i can relate to just not
really feeling comfortable with a
specific title
like i i get that feeling a lot when i
don't really know
like what i feel like i fit in as
yeah i think the sometimes i just don't
like that whole conversation it's just
like
you know it's just it's what it is i
don't know
yeah you just kind of it sounds like you
just have your hands in a lot of
different things because you come from
the tech
world so yeah also like the tech and the
talent right i think she's playing it
down though she's a revolutionary
and the v2 world you've got i mean come
on look at that
don't be modest i really
don't i think i i think i just came in
at the right time
you know so who do you get more
donations as yourself
or as you get more donations when
when uh when mikko is on
well okay wait wait wait wait wait i get
more
donations as myself but i get more
uh bids subs like in total
like my income is a lot larger when i'm
we go
because um the way i set up mikko is
initially because now's a little bit
less but i'm gonna go back to
it being that um but
i i initially set up set her up as like
a live arcade
so um people could throw
25 bids and make something happen
yeah and um doing that making
designing my twitch stream like that
actually helped me
um afford everything as
i was going because with how much
everything costs
um you wouldn't be able to continue the
project as a 200 viewer streamer
um considering like two traditionally
200 viewers
at 200 viewers you don't make enough to
have it be a full-time job right and
then for me it was like i had to have it
be enough
for me to pay my bills and pay my
equipment
and you know pay for anything else that
i needed for the project
right um so i when i did this arcade
uh type of thing where you know people
would throw bits and things would happen
and they would also get content out of
it i was able to
you know sustain myself at a much
smaller viewership and so
i thought i guess i got really really
lucky and like
just uh for some reason just blew up
and like like really fast well i think
the way you did it is just so
like so unusual and it's just kind of
shocking like to see
it done so well like when you first
started you would just sit there
without moving and then when someone
donated you would animate yourself
oh um well one of the one of the things
that they like to do
is um to nuke migo
so um they'll throw a bomb and
kill me though in a in a video game
cartoon way
and things like that where they can
directly affect her and her animation
and her
and her environment um
people just really like doing it i
noticed that viewers really love
annoying streamers
he finds so much joy in that and
so i just basically made a lot of like
things where they can you know
make her annoyed and um
yeah that was that was mostly it just
did you need to put in
an initial investment to get started
like oh my god
only yes yeah i i spent
when i first started um because i got
laid off from work
our entire team got laid off from work
because of
budget issues and um
i basically
i was really interested in doing live
animation with twitch
because twitch is a streaming platform
right and so i thought it'd be
perfect for that and also
i was like i i was a game designer
hobbyist
meaning i like to play i like i like to
make games
in my spare time with unreal engines so
um i thought to kind of cross all that
and create niko but to do that
i basically had to spend like um
20 i was like 20 000 in debt wow
that was the initial startup cost yeah
yeah and then
and then like this apartment i
specifically
i specifically got for my job um
to be really close to it uh but when i
lost my job
it was like i had a one-year lease and
yeah
la la is not right no um
yeah so um i was like
paying a lot of bills i was like in
twenty thousand dollars of debt
um the first month of streaming on
twitch i think i made like three bucks
um so it was like i struggled a lot for
like three months
yeah but that was kind of a gamble it
sounds like
interesting yeah it was really stressful
because um
you know you you know yourself that
twitch is really really hard to
break through um i actually got
lucky in my like second or third stream
where i got hosted and then like my one
of my clips got
onto lsf and so i was able to get like
my first 50 viewers and like quickly get
up to like a hundred viewers
um wow that was exciting
yeah yeah yeah it was really exciting
and i could see like
oh it working but um oh you were online
what happened on live stream fails what
clip was on there
it was literally it was just it was just
me walking like nothing nothing happened
i think people are just right did
nothing happen or was it just
intriguing this avatar yeah it was just
i was just walking and that clip just
got a lot of views you have that clip
baby can you pull it up
yeah let me check one of these guys
we'll pull it up
we have we have a discord over there
really wait do they know which clip it
is
they'll figure it out oh wow
a lot of speculation about how much your
setup cost
with your suit and everything you're
doing now like what would you say
is your investment now on all your gear
and everything
if i discount everything yes
um okay wait can i get i'm gonna get a
calculator yeah
i like it let's get
one more thing yep get it all in there
wait like how much i guess
hmm
i feel like i could guess really high or
really low are we talking about like
now everything including right now
everything
all in oh my god
yeah i want to know everything because
look you ever
it takes a lot to do what you do and i
want to know you know how much you're
going to be
yeah okay okay yeah
go get it all the way i mean i have a
number in my head can i guess
wait i think i'm gonna get a discount on
something so
no i'm not gonna add that in there oh
you're getting you're
you can ignore the discount let's go
really i mean how much of a discount are
you getting
okay well all right i'm just gonna say
that i think that's a very safe number i
think it's a little bit
should we guess a little bit yeah you
guys can guess because
i'm afraid okay let me see because you
said you spent 20 000 just to get
started right
yeah and you've come a long way since
then right
yeah in terms of your gear and stuff
yeah
i was gonna i was thinking a hundred
thousand i was like
i thought you were gonna you were you're
in like 50 000.
uh hey that's actually
really close yeah it's like 52
000. wow wow that's an expensive
that's a big investment yeah
that's kind of interesting because it
kind of it's almost like a
it's not something everyone can do um
well they have a credit card right there
i guess
although maybe and a really good credit
score
um there you go that's a good point
a lot of it is like
the thing like a lot of like almost
everything i make on stream i put it
back
to my stream yeah so um
once i started go get it like going i
was able to kind of
redirect my funds but to get started
honestly i
to just get started i would say like
around 20 grand
that's amazing that's a lot that's
really cool that you had the foresight
to do that though
for my setup though you can get it way
cheaper
um so let me ask you this i know that
there's a lot of creepy dudes and
people who get really obsessed with
youtubers have you had any weird
obsessed
fans in your career no wow
weird yeah i've gotten some weird
messages
here and there but i mean i'm
really in my own little world right
because i
i stream and then i work on my stream so
even if they tried
like what are they like
it sounds like nothing in here i just i
saw some really
funny donations that we pulled up from
other youtubers like
ah just messages of like a wild hold on
we got a clip from love's live stream
fail can she see this dan
i don't think so if i take it full
screen i think she will be able to see
it yeah this is something from live
stream phil
ah hard is you see that stream in devon
yeah i see it i see it
is this really old or is this it this
isn't it is it
oh no no this is not it this is really
interesting though let me watch this
right when it comes to like an organic
um innovative type of stream oh her
mouth is amazing
yeah so i didn't have her i didn't have
her face cooked up
on this one got it here's one that we
saw here's one we found i don't know
which streamer this was on but
i have grown really attached to you
which means i think about your
well-being every day
and take every burden you have on myself
with the hope you feel better
wish i could do more but can't and that
breaks me every day promise one day i
would do more than
donate i was like oh boy i have one
person
like like threaten me
i mean but i don't really
i did i do get these but i feel like i
just they're just kind of me they're not
necessarily that serious
yeah it's like it doesn't it like just
kind of goes away from my
mind do you get stuff like can we see
your feet like what is what are people
into
yeah the people love their feet for some
reason
that's awesome yeah we're very curious
about defeat
do you know you know if mikko has a wiki
feet
i have a i have a clip of me
deliberately showing mikko's feet
yeah i can show that to you
guys yeah let's see i'm ready dude
this one is the first this one is like
the the the clip that got me my first
initial
viewers oh great can oh you got it ian
just sent it to me
great there's a pop-up do you see that i
got it from ian so here it is i'm gonna
watch this
so no nate wait oh this is the feet clip
oh that
that one is the feet clip let's watch
the feet okay hold on now and you have
to go to like
this this it starts slow so oh i'm
patient for feet
okay what do you think i don't have feet
or something
no that's that's a ploy they just want
to see your toes
she dances and cooks yeah i can dance
and
cook and hi winfrey how are you doing
she'll fee
sophie dude that must have blown their
minds though
yeah yeah because they're like that's
the genius of what you do
nobody could ever lift their boot and be
like i have feet
and legs
oh my god and it's perfect too like the
motion
yeah yeah oh but where's toes show toes
not boots show toes she has smoke
she can't
why they're so weird there you could
show it here on this show
i don't know to be honest i've heard so
many different things
that's so weird i mean it's just faith i
guess they're just they
so does does mikko have toes she does
she has toes
so what how complete is her anatomy
she's fully uh
she's full she has nipples she used to
what happened to her nipples there was a
bug where
when she was switch outfits or sometimes
when
so she's got morphs meaning there's um
things that can shift her body and like
make her
larger or make her you know muscular
um so there was a bug where
sometimes if someone threw
like if someone i don't i can't figure
out exactly
what caused it it could be a level
change it could be
someone triggering something in chat um
it could be a bunch of things but there
was a bug
where her skin inside would pop out
clothes yeah yeah and
and they were and okay so when you make
a like a body
right a human character body and when
you texture it
um you get you don't really think like
oh let's photoshop out the nipples
because you just get
like the reference photos right in you
and you put it
you paint it in you do your thing um
and you make it as realistic as possible
right um but you don't really think like
oh
photoshop with nipples i just thought
like no one's gonna see them so
who cares right um
but yeah the they they you know you can
see how
that could so that you end up did you
end up showing nipples on twitch by a
bug
or you were just afraid of it happening
i can't say
oh i can't see it
what about the genitals are those fully
no no no no no no no
just curious is there like a butthole or
is that just
uh usually when you like model it
a body you don't there's no that area
you don't really map out that right
you know okay just curious just asking
questions
that's where all the seams go yeah got
it
so you could show her feet if it wasn't
for twitch
oh yeah yeah yeah i can i can show she's
got a full body
underneath her clothes um there's some
things i'm doing now to like
because i'm scared of uh they're
they're not they don't [ __ ] around no no
i think i think i found it is this it
is this the clip that blew up in uh
that's my initial one that gave me my
first this is your first clip ever
yeah it's just me walking oh wow your
model's come a long way in terms of yeah
yeah but i still see how impressive it
is
look at this wow
that's awesome
yeah this must have i mean this must
have blown people's minds
[Music]
it didn't appear yeah yeah
dude that looks amazing yeah
it's just me walking yeah but it's so
freaking it's cool it's so crazy
it's gone a long way for sure
wow so this is this is the clip huh
yeah that's really fun actually that got
me my initial view
i gotta say it's really impressive seems
really fun for someone who's shy
to be able to just kind of like have
this uh
persona oh i
oh because i'm shy like do you think i'm
shy
oh well that's what you said i think is
reflected i'm also kind of like
referring to myself like i'm shy so i'm
thinking like
it seems like i would enjoy doing it
because you don't actually
you know yeah it's not your real body it
kind of
yeah liberating you can kind of go crazy
i mean
when i so i have another character in
which i'm me
and i call her the technician um and
when i'm doing technician i'm also
playing a character so
what is this i play it up as technician
as well it's fun
what is this you show off your apartment
it's like a full on
like 3d oh yeah so one of the things
that
uh one of her features is that she is a
game character
um so her story is that she's a failed
game character
so that's why she's trying to make it on
twitch um
so because of that she can go into like
certain game modes like
being a third person rpg uh
please like walk through so that's kind
of what you see there
jesus yeah that's amazing okay
so this must have blown people's minds
too yeah
you are on the next you are really
something i mean this is incredible you
you are unbelievable so this is just my
adhd
making but um because it's kind of like
a decrease
oh this is sick
so you were working on this whole 3d
world just ready
just waiting for this to show up your
apartment um
um i'm sorry this show opened my phone
before sorry i think the audi the double
audio let me just watch this clip
okay it's got scary music i could
basically go back to my mogak form like
this
see that i'm making
the kings a little bit better but
so you were you were working on this
whole kind of 3d world in secret just
waiting for someone to ask you to show
off your apartment
yes dude this is insane you are
so thoughtful i cannot believe this
what was the reaction when you felt that
talented huh
what was their reaction when you showed
your apartment off like that
oh people were people were
talking yeah
they thought it was really really cool
and yeah it's
awesome to think that people think what
i'm making is
cool um i i
just i yeah i mean i'm just kind of like
i don't know what the big deal is
because i think anybody can do it
well clearly there's a lot of people
that can create a 3d world but it's the
way you've done it where you're like
oh yeah i can show you my apartment like
it's just mind-blowing that like
you did that and thank you guys so i'm
assuming you're working on some other
crazy [ __ ] in her world
yeah i'm so excited oh my god
i think um one of one of the things i
really
enjoy for myself is like creating games
like i'm not the best developer i'm a
terrible engineer honestly i think
but um but i just like to make
things even if it's like even if it
turns out
really buggy or bad it's just kind of
fun to experiment with stuff
um but so currently i'm kind of
experimenting with different types of
games that amigo can have on our stream
and
um when i come back i'm going to
try out like my first game show with
multiple streamers
and that's gonna be really fun but one
of the big one of the biggest things
i've been working on for a while now
um is like a miko rpg world
where yeah where she takes her chat
on an adventure and we go out to defeat
bosses and all the bosses will be like
big streamers
like um like casual navi or like miss
kim and they'll have like their special
attacks and
there are special moves and things yeah
and they'll be like niko and chat
working together to defeat
yeah thank you so much yeah
yeah i'm not looking okay wait i can't
go off the rails
you can keep talking i'm interested um
no no no i can't because
because okay if it's a surprise so
here's the thing
when can we get an only fans for mikko
so we can see her toes
oh my god i'm kind of like i love
debating and joking around with with my
audience
so i was like thinking maybe i should
just make like only fans but just
pictures of fans you know the stakes
i mean i don't think it's against the
rules but i think people want to see the
toes i'm just saying
mikko's toes are kind of gross to be
honest
they're textured really bad right now
well i'm very glad to have talked to you
i mean your whole
journey your whole story everything
you're doing is fascinating
and i'm very happy to announce to all of
our
viewers that you'll be back on twitch
this friday you can find her
code miko you are on like a month
let's say a month uh
hiatus yes
around the month yeah like three weeks
three weeks two weeks
brutal yeah
but you're back on friday yeah i'm back
on friday
and i'm actually it was like a blessing
in disguise because i got to like form a
team
and because before i was doing
everything pretty much by myself
and um it was a lot
but i spent like my three weeks getting
like
um devs modelers animators
yes so i can just so i can push the
content further and i could just focus
on um my youtube or my streaming
and is that is that a huge hit to your
revenue to be gone for three weeks
that's a long time in the world of
streaming right
oh my gosh it's brutal it wasn't
just that it was yeah it
it was a major was it how how was your
mental health during that time when you
got
like a three gone for three weeks um
well i just
honestly i was fine because i i just you
know thought about like
the silver lining positive stuff about
it
and i i wanted to take a break so that i
can
make more stuff because the whole
december and a lot of january
um because i blew up so fast or i grew
so fast
i didn't have time to like because
before what i would do
is i would this was my schedule it was
kind of maddening but
um i would um
i would go to sleep at 9 00 p.m
wake up at 2 am dev until 12 p.m
stream at stream at 12 30
uh end my stream eat and you
and then it would it would be like that
but now
that's crazy yeah and then when i grew
it's like i had all these other things
that i had to worry about
yeah um my youtube
my socials are not more important um
youtube is super important now yeah um
and then it's like what's your youtube
just called mikko
yeah it's called migo yeah well you guys
know what to do
let me go to your youtube is it just
clips from twitch it's just
it's edited interviews on my twitch
channel
and um yes pretty much
all of it is just my twitch content at
the moment
i want to do more like youtube
like just for youtube content and one of
the ideas
that i think would be hilarious to make
a video for
is i want to figure out how to mocap my
cat
to mocap my cat oh wow
oh that'd be crazy i can't i want to
make a
motion cap got it that'd be fun i'll
make like a youtube video
of me mo capping my cat that would
definitely blow people's minds
you need help though yeah you definitely
need help yeah
you can't that's yeah you need sleep
come on especially when you're
all especially when you're as old as me
and you yeah
but good news though is because of my
three weeks
i was able to get a team i'm glad that's
awesome
well not now because i'm not sleeping
because of my return stream
because i have so much to do for that
but is it going to be that schedule
again
12 p.m huh two ways to wake up are you
gonna continue that schedule
it's that's not you that's not
sustainable
is worried about you yeah
no because i noticed that i would get
too tired when i'm
swimming so now it's more like
i wake up you know i do my morning thing
i stream
i well this is my ideal schedule i
stream and then i will work on my things
and then relax great sleep
that's my ideal schedule yeah that
sounds
normal yeah well anyway me uh code miko
on friday everybody tune in thank you so
much for coming and sharing your story
with us it was really great and really
nice to
to hear from you yeah thank you for
joining us thank you guys you guys were
lovely
all right uh good luck on friday i'm
going to be there i'll be watching
i'll be asking for feet uh for tokyo
be donating you'll notice all right i'll
look out for you yeah
okay all right all right talk to you bye
bye
code miko is amazing by the way i am the
cute little anime girl now and ela's the
burger
so she's like the coolest person ever um
that whole apartment tour is blew my
freaking mind
right you just love being the burger you
can't get over it
i think she's awesome i hope you guys go
watch her i'm going to watch her on
friday
get some feed picks or whatever i can
you know hey whoa he was on my titties
so let's see if i can bounce my titties
better than ela yeah look how good i'm
at bouncing oh you're just moving your
head yeah this side
interesting anyway that's the show
anyone else have anything to say as we
ended up
[ __ ] drunk look at this guy say what
are we looking at pewdiepie pewdiepie
had a stroke somebody called the police
pewdiepie what the heck is going on
pewdiepie
yeah why are you having a stroke
sounds like you've lost uh
some circulation there
when the eyes go in the black and it
looks like an eye
oh my god this is such okay let's wrap
it up because this is just
i'm trying to make my titties mouse
people don't even know what i'm doing
because they can't
see me because he's my character all
right everybody get this is your shot
all right is there anything else anyone
anything nope that's it that's it
all right thank you everybody i hope you
enjoyed the show we will see you on
friday for a after dark
experience all right uh the
thank you food picks please
[Music]